[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice chrissy wright ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
is my co-host today if you want to talk
about your life and your money this is
your place you can get in if you dial at
this moment
the number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two
five five two two five we launched the
pre-sale on christy's brand new book
take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance
and the book is selling like crazy in
pre-sale
actually we will be delivering them to
your home in september
and uh at the actual launch date but if
you buy as a pre-order you get
all kinds of goodies 50 worth of stuff
including the ebook
including the audiobook as read by the
author
it's all there take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance by
christy wright you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com and christy tonight
we have a
big event yeah this is exciting because
we have been building up to this
in celebration of the launch of the new
book and getting ready for
it to be here september 14th but tonight
we are doing a free
digital event on facebook and youtube
and you can register at
ramseysolutions.com
balance and i'm going to be walking you
through
the four root causes of why we feel out
of balance because what i've noticed is
this topic of balance we have a lot of
feelings about it
different people have different
definitions we don't really know what it
is we're just sure we don't have it
and so i'm going to help people
understand what it is and what it isn't
and then what keeps us from feeling that
sense of balance we've been looking for
and we're gonna talk about those four
root causes because when you know what's
keeping you from it
you can know what to do about it so
that's gonna be seven o'clock tonight
and i'm gonna be doing a q a afterwards
so if people want to tune in live they
can ask their question and i'll
i'll walk them through it very cool good
stuff
so 7 p.m central time tonight
free on youtube or on facebook
and if you want to pre-register for that
and have an rsvp we'll send you a link
out
make sure it's easy for you to connect
up and you'll be able to watch this talk
tonight
as christy walks you through this whole
idea of uh balance and you know the
enemies of it where it's coming from
where it's going to all those sorts of
things so ramsay solutions
dot com slash balance
you know what's interesting is is that i
we've talked about this so much that
that uh
it feels like i've overdone it but um
that maybe balance isn't the problem and
what you said a minute ago that um
it may just be that there's too much i
mean
i'm not sure you're balancing the food
on your plate if you have too much food
on your plate yeah
yeah that's not a balance problem the
plate's fine it didn't tip over
right but it's just got too much on it
yeah and it's interesting too because i
think we
we throw around this term and we say
work life balance and life balance and
all of that but what's interesting is we
can do
all the things we think we're supposed
to do to have balance
where we manage our calendar and we're
super productive and we you know have
time
off and take vacations all those things
but we can still
feel as if something's missing we can
still feel like we're doing all the
things right
and something still feels off and that's
because i think that what we're
asking when we're asking about balance
is really something different than what
we want i think what we really want
is to be confident how we spend our time
be proud of how we spend our time be
confident
in our choices when we say yes to this
thing or no to that thing versus feeling
guilty and questioning
you know am i doing the wrong thing i
think we want peace in a
chaotic world and so and i think we want
to be in be happy and enjoy our life and
so
what if we talked about balance
differently and said okay it's not this
balancing act which feels stressful and
you can do all that and still not feel
like things are right
and what if instead it looks more like
peace and the chaos and and being
confident in your choices and that's the
type of balance that
that we want it's more about being a
balanced person in an out of balance
world
versus just perfectly walking the tight
rope which is not realistic or fun in my
opinion
yeah you may you may want to talk about
this subject as well as anything else
jump in the phone numbers are triple
eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five i like
what
marcus buckingham our friend said about
that um
it's as if if you ever do get everything
just right
everybody freeze yeah don't move because
as soon as you
flinch one direction or the other all of
a sudden that quote balance
unquote is gone yeah and um
you know you you do lose yourself in
that process
and there's a i think that
there's been a little bit of a guilt
tripping to say the least uh in the
culture about this idea that
okay you're not nurturing enough okay
you're not productive enough
uh you're not working enough um you're
not enough
right and then we we threw that in the
bucket of
out of balance yeah and what's
interesting is when we put the pressure
on ourselves
to balance everything whether you use
the analogy of juggling all the balls
spinning the plates walking the
tightrope whatever
50 50 split this perfect pie that's
equally divided
whatever you use as your metric of
success for balance that looks like that
you're setting yourself up to fail but
then what's really dangerous dave and i
see this all the time and women i work
with and men too for that matter
is it because when you can't do that
because you can't and you won't
it's not realistic or sustainable in any
way then what happens is it spins up
this narrative in your mind that you're
failing at everything
you're failing at your job you're
failing your family you're just failing
yeah
everything in balance with my family
then i'm a bad mom a bad dad
if i don't have anything in balance with
my work uh then i'm a bad leader
yeah a bad a bad employee yeah yeah so
you it's almost like the identity shifts
off of this one subject yeah and it
drastically affects how you experience
your own life there are people walking
around
every day there's people listening right
now that feel like they're failing
and they're not maybe they can be more
intentional with how they manage your
calendar maybe they can be more
intentional with putting their phone
away
but they're not failing and so i want to
get that's why i love the tagline of
this book
the guilt-free guide to life balance
because i think the undercurrent of the
issue is this guilt that haunts us and
what i want people to understand is yes
i'll help you manage your calendar yes
i'll help you
you know use best practices to be
productive and do the right things at
the right time
but it's not really about the calendar
it's about enjoying the life that the
calendar represents
and feeling balanced remember you're in
control of the calendar counters not in
control of you yes
yeah you put it on there yeah so you can
take it off that's right
uh you cannot put it on there that's a
really good one there
and i think there's a certain amount of
hyperbole a certain amount of drama has
been added to the whole subject
uh we were with some friends the other
night and uh
he's opening a business and so he's
spent a lot of time
opening a business it always is when
you're doing that and uh his wife
said well he's just a workaholic and
we're fairly good friends since i said
i'm
so curious what she said i'm calling bs
he's not a workaholic a workaholic is
someone who's addicted to their work and
gets
all of their juice from work that is not
him
he's paying a price right now to get a
business open he's gonna see that is not
workaholism quit giving it names it's
not
so you can throw around the fact that
maybe he didn't make the bed like you
wanted him to
um so this is what dinner with us sounds
like that's right but i mean really it's
just you know
she thought she completely threw her
husband on the bus yeah and he's not
a workaholic there are workaholics but
everybody that works hard
is not a workaholic right so we have to
quit throwing the hyperbole on this
stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones as we talk about your life
and your money here on
the ramsey show it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five ron's with us in
washington d.c
hey ron how are you hey dave i'm a big
fan of since 07. how are you
better than i deserve sir how can we
help i've got a quick question sort of a
philosophical spiritual angle to things
um
i know you guys are big you know big
into spending and living a legacy
i've got twin girls 14 years old i've
lost who knows how many jobs over the
past
you know a couple years i wasn't even
working a year ago now i am
thank the good lord i know you're big
about saving and you know for
spending for you know and saving for the
future and
but as believers in christ obviously we
uh believe in the rapture where our lord
could come back at any time
so say he did come back in the next five
minutes
all the money that you saved for you
know is kind of
not null and void but you know i'm not
saying why is saved because jesus is
going to come back and
we don't know in any moment does this
soul sort of make sense am i just crazy
or am i just
you know i'm not saying don't save but
i'm also saying that
you know say your christian members of
your family are not
you save your money for them because
obviously once they and again i'm
going a lot of things here in the
methodist background you go through the
tribulation period
you know and i've read you know tim
lahaye and jim jenkins books
you know that i i don't even know is
this all making sense
well i mean there's kind of two things
pulling at this um
number one it's very good uh i think
it'll
increase the quality of your life while
you're here
and the the quality of your
decision-making on money and other
things if you have what you have which
is an eternal perspective
i'm not thinking of uh 50 years and i'm
dirt
okay you're thinking beyond that you're
thinking uh
differently than that otherworldly than
that and that gives you a
an advantage because someone who has the
broader perspective
generally makes better decisions and so
that's the beauty of an eternal
perspective um
then if you did within that context
you're kind of got two things
pulling at you um one is that
once we're dead or raptured uh
instantaneously money's not important
and anything you've acquired is
instantaneously one second later
none of this matters right
right so okay wait wait so
the point the point being that the
bumper sticker is right
he with the most toys when he dies is
dead which is kind of your point right
and then then the other side of that is
the wisdom
with an eternal perspective of living my
life
in a way that is mature that is
thoughtful and wise uh that does leave
a financial legacy for my family behind
life insurance a will savings
paid for assets those kinds of things
which also line up
biblically without being inconsistent
with the other thing
so what we're saying is we don't we
don't rest our eternal hopes
on the stuff but proverbs does say
in the house of the wise are
stores this is the bible
of choice food and oil and a foolish man
devours all he has even if he used a
spiritual reason
to devour all he has and have no savings
he would be by biblical definition a
foolish man
exactly and so these two things appear
to be a juxtaposition with each other
while i and i think if you take a step
up above it you go no they're not
i'm not going to rest on the depth of my
real estate portfolio i'm not going to
worship at that altar
and i don't want my kids to either
uh and so that's the eternal perspective
of idol worship and so forth and on the
other hand i've got this
this mandate by my maker to be wise
christie
yeah it's interesting because i think
sometimes we like to and you can apply
this to anything swing to extremes
and assume these things are mutually
exclusive and i think it's exactly like
you're saying dave we're going to hold
these two truths where
we're going to fix our eyes on internal
things our hope is in our eternal
destination and while god has us here
today
we're going to do what we can with what
we have where we are which means just
being a good
steward and so what we know today is
we're here and we need money as a tool
to fund our lifestyle to take care of
our family after we're gone and so on so
we're gonna do that in the name of
stewarding
god's blessings and we're gonna know
exactly like you said dave our hope is
not in this this is not the end game
we have an eternal perspective it's not
either or it's both you can hold both of
those at the same time those
truths i'm just going to say that i've
heard the phrase you know
you're you're so heavily minded you're
generally good yeah
and then on the other hand you're so
materialistic you forgot god
exactly that's the other end of that
right and so so and really we're not we
don't even have to play on that spectrum
we can go up above that at a completely
different
point on the diagram and let's go
three-dimensional instead of a linear
perspective
between materialism and spirituality as
if there is as if that's the only part
of the spectrum
so i mean we're called all throughout
scripture to manage
things and love people the
minimalists were on the other day and
that's the title of their new book love
people
use things don't use people and love
things
i heard that conversation great it's a
great title for a book i mean because it
just
it encapsulates everything that you
brought up and uh so what's the legacy
that we want these 14 year old twins to
have
we want them to have a high quality life
living here with wisdom which puts them
financially in a position not only to
take care of their own household first
or they're worse than an unbeliever
but also to be generous to widows and
orphans because they have the money
to be generous right to widows i'm just
going to say if they
and if the rapture comes then they're in
a higher place they'll have to worry
about the crap down here so it's
i'd be happy to leave all of this behind
and let it burn
wouldn't make me mad at all i'm ready to
go come quickly lord jesus
i mean this it's crazy and crud out
there come quickly lord
but i i don't know the day or the hour
and scripture's pretty clear i'm not
going to
and so meantime i gotta live with what i
got here and manage this thing
uh until i don't have to manage it
anymore and uh
and and the beautiful part about that is
the management of
stuff and keeping stuff in its place
spiritually is and transferring
that skill to your kids is character
building
it builds your character builds your
spiritual character well well the
one thing i've learned is that they both
started summer jobs this this year
yeah you know rather than going during
summer camps they're they're
they're working so much they're making
more than their father you know who
you know part-time stay at home debt
i've worked from home i haven't even
before the pandemic yeah
and i'm like your checks are more than
mine but but the thing is i've noticed
this with with my younger daughter
she is more like we actually just gotta
get lunch she will go in order for
herself i'm like you want to come with
me no
she never did that before it's huge
character building name yeah
fantastic yeah it's and see that's you
and what we're discussing here is not
the actual amount it's what's happened
in their hearts
as they've engaged in these act in these
earthly
activities how their spirits have grown
right exactly and so that's the that's
this uh
weird dance that we do uh as christians
and as people of faith that this weird
dance
between the earthly possessions if you
believe all earthly possessions are
evil and to own anything is evil
that is not actually a christian track
that's a track called
gnosticism and it was a toxic form
a her a heretical form of christianity
that popped up in the third century
i was going to say it goes back to the
ancient greeks exactly yeah and it was
born out of that but then they took it
and put it over
with an overlay on uh you know what we
would have called judeo-christian ethic
and
and shifted it and so and then that's
that's translated into today's world
with people who are ignorant of theology
and doctrine
who start to say things like well all
rich people are evil
because they have money oh and rich
people can't go to heaven which by the
way is
not in the bible but a lot of people
quote the bible that had never read it
and so this is a very interesting
discussion hey i appreciate you calling
in thanks for letting us
kick that can around with you because
it's uh you know it's something we don't
do often enough around here we should
stop and do that kind of thing good
yeah very very good stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national
guard can help you get there visit
nationalguard.com
to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host
today mitchell and courtney are with us
in dallas texas it says on my screen you
guys are debt-free congratulations
thank you very cool how much have you
paid off
we go ahead we paid off 86 000
congratulations how long did this take
22 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh 125 000 to 127
000 but in that time courtney
took a pay increase and i took a pay
decrease so that's why
the such small increase that works but
22 months so two years you pay off 86
000 43 000 a year making 125 that's
beans and rice you were careful
yes sir what kind of uh what kind of
debt was the 86
000 it was about 60 000
of college loans uh truck loan
uh for twenty four thousand dollars and
uh two thousand dollars of credit cards
wow how long you two been married uh
four years in december
okay so what happened what happened 22
months ago that changed her mind about
this debt
i got a job about an hour away from
where we lived this was right after
buying a house the wrong way
and i was looking for a podcast to
listen to
and uh yours showed up so i started
listening to it
i was on board immediately uh courtney
took a little bit of convincing though
and uh just so happened that there was a
money and marriage seminar coming to
dallas that year
and uh got courtney to go to it and
she was all in wow okay so that would
have been
rachel cruz unless parrot then yes yeah
they're funny that's cool
that's a fun night good that's a that's
a good seminar
good good good so uh courtney you go to
that thing after your husband's been
hanging out with this weird guy in a car
for an hour every day
two hours every day um and you go to
this uh
uh seminar what was going through your
head
um at first like i mean i knew the
principles and everything and so
it was just more i'm a very uh visual
person
so it was just actually like seeing it
in practice
and the way rachel talked about it it
just
really got to me and it just made
complete sense
so i think as soon as we got home from
the seminar we sat down and we figured
out
how much debt we had and i think at that
point time when we saw the amount that's
when i was really on board
yeah like oh crud we got to do something
about this it's amazing how
events can be so motivating and so
inspiring that even if they tell you
something you already know if they
present it in a way like rachel did like
lest it
in a way that that fires you up and
makes you care and gets you excited
that's what actually can be the catalyst
just because they presented it in a way
that got you fired up
it absolutely was yeah that's awesome
way to go guys
way to go all right so two years you
crunch away
what was the secret during his two years
to paying off 86
000 uh definitely working as a team
uh both of us kind of had our weak
moments
so we really had to rely on each other
to make sure we kept to our budget
and then making sure that we kept our
eye on the prize like
chris hogan says we need a dream in hd
and i know exactly what we're working
towards so we just kept telling
ourselves
what our goals were and we just needed
to make it
past paying off all the debt and we
could get there yeah
great job who uh who were your biggest
cheerleaders through this whole process
honestly all of our friends and family
were really behind us they were really
in our corner cheers
cheering us on and in fact my parents
actually
they they got so excited about they
started the plan themselves
and now they're there on the dave ramsey
plan too that's
awesome you've spread this through the
family way to go
a ripple effect that's really cool how
old are you two
i uh we're both 27. yep okay
and you're debt-free 86 000
paid off how's that feel surreal to say
the least
very freeing we can focus on uh
putting money towards everything we want
we recently found out that we're
expecting well congratulations
thank you yeah so yeah we can just put
the money towards the baby
um we were actually able to refinance
our house in a dave approved manner
so we're excited about that too that's
awesome
congratulations so proud of you guys
what a great start you've got
on life and for this baby very very well
done
and all because you just decided you're
going to take control
because this was no small feat i mean
you you have really leaned into this
this is
you've been hustling and grinding for
two years this is really tough wasn't it
there there were certainly some really
tough days but when i looked back at it
it it went by really quick good
will you ever go back ever go back into
debt
so next time you get ready to buy a car
oh we're actually saving up for a car so
we can pay in cash
there you go that's the right answer
you're passing the quiz
way to go y'all are awesome very very
cool heroes well done
completely changed the family tree of
this baby that's on the way excellent
excellent excellent
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
because that's what you've done
changed your legacy a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away to
someone get their journey
started way to go mitchell and courtney
dallas texas
86 thousand dollars paid off in 22
months
making 125 to 127. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream all right
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
way to go you guys absolutely incredible
wow that's fun that's awesome very fun
zach is in milwaukee hey zach welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going today better
than i deserve what's up
uh i am currently desperate as of march
they also asked my student loans
and i'm looking to move out on my own i
was curious should i
find a cheaper place to rent and save up
the money and buy it with
most of the a physical money or should i
take a 15-year mortgage
i'm a truck driver making about 58 a
year before taxes
okay how much can you save a year
as much as i can i don't try i don't
know as
much as i can is not an answer how much
money can you save a year
if i go hard i'll probably say two
thirds of my check
okay so let's call it 35 thousand forty
thousand
somewhere in there yes okay and uh how
expensive a home are you thinking about
buying
uh with me being not married and no kids
that i know of uh looking about 70 000
maybe
okay and so if you took if it was thirty
thousand that you thirty five thousand a
year that you were saving and you were
gonna buy seventy thousand it would take
you two years does that sound right
about right yes i am currently not
renting stuff with mom and dad so
there's gonna be that expense
are you over the road driving or home or
local driver
uh regional i'm home on weekends okay
all right so you're gone most the time
already
yeah and so um
you know it'd be pretty tempting to me
if you if you can buy something for 70
000 in your area that
that suits your needs be tempting to me
if you could do that in two years to pay
cash
we don't yell at people for taking out a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage
where the payment's no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay but we
certainly
always encourage the 100 down plan when
we can yeah and if especially if you if
you got you know 75
of the way there let's say you rent and
the rent ate away at your your income
more than you thought well you're a lot
closer than you would have be if you
didn't try that plan so it doesn't hurt
to try for it and set that goal
yeah i mean what if you saved up 30 000
bucks and you put that down on the house
and you got a little 40 000 mortgage and
you knock it out in a year
knock it out over the next two years or
something that's that's very doable too
right i mean that's kind of a mid-range
that's not all the way to a 15-year fix
that's a
like a two-year mortgage but you take
out a 15 but pay it off in two
yeah and you probably just get that at
your local credit union your local bank
you're not going to get a
a small amount like that for a short
period of time
a traditional mortgage company like a
churchill mortgage company they don't
they don't make a 35 or a 40 000
loan because the you know the fannie mae
secondary markets
fha won't accept those you got to get 50
75
000 minimum and even then it's kind of
expensive so you got these under 100 000
mortgages most of the time you're gonna
do that with your local bank your credit
union those kinds of things
so hey good stuff man you're thinking
zach good question thinking you're
thinking you're thinking
this is the ramsey shower
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825-5225 if you want to
talk about your life and your money
we're here to help nathaniel's with us
in louisville kentucky hi nathaniel how
are you
i'm doing well thank you for taking my
call ramsey sure how can we help
hey um i just finished to pay off my
house
and i need some financial advice on
what else to do with the money after you
max out your 401k
and your rock for the wife and me
what other investments are good to keep
doing so you can
you know keep building your your
portfolio way to go man congratulations
baby step seven huh yeah
well i i never did any of the step i
just
use biblical principles to to grow okay
money i'll take that i didn't hear from
you a lot yeah
good well thanks good so uh but anyway
you're 100
debt free right yes good
good okay well what uh what i have done
and what we've recommended in those
situations
is do what you've done let's max out all
available
anything to keep the government's hands
off the money in any kind of a
retirement plan 401ks
as you said roth iras as you said if
you've got any self-employment income of
any kind
you can look at a self-employed pension
plan but even then that maxes out pretty
quick
and then what i personally have done is
two things
you can do whatever you want but this is
what i have done and what we have
recommended
i have invested in mutual funds now at
this point you want to invest in mutual
funds that have what's called a low
turnover ratio and the turnover ratio is
how often they sell the stocks
inside the mutual funds if it has a a
four percent turnover ratio that means
96
of the portfolio does not sell every
year
that's pretty cool so if it doesn't sell
then as it increases in value
there's no taxes on it until you do sell
it
so just like if you buy a single share
of stock and it goes up in value you do
not pay taxes on it
until you sell it the other thing i do
is i buy real estate that i pay cash for
so my first goal when i did when i hit
where you are
years ago is i just started dumping
money in a low turnover mutual fund you
can do that like an s p 500 fund no load
if you want that's what i did
and just dump money in there and when it
got enough when i got enough money in
that account to buy a piece of real
estate i'd buy a piece of real estate
then i'd dump money in there until i got
enough money in there
to buy a piece of another piece of real
estate and i would buy another piece of
real estate because i'm
i love real estate but you may or may
not that's the two things i've invested
in
well that's great great idea i
appreciate that thank you thank you man
thanks for the advice
i appreciate your call dave do you have
do you have a um a formula or a
percentage
like in that scenario if someone was
going to do both where they were going
to do some real estate and some just
just putting in an investment do you
have any kind of percentage or use
whatever you're comfortable with
whatever you're interested in just
whatever you're comfortable with
um mine has resulted in being
much heavier real estate yeah because
you love real estate hey i love real
estate but the other thing that happened
was 2008.
yeah yeah i bought like uh
about 200 million worth of real estate
in 2008
for about 20 million wow about 10 cents
on the dollar
real estate was just a it was on sales
on fire sale
so consequently my net worth is lopsided
just from the fact that i got that i
stole that stuff right
and that changed it but uh so even more
so than just
investing steadily into it i just i just
caught that wave
the best wave of my entire 60-year life
yeah in terms of the market being way
down and it was really
good for people who had money right to
buy stuff while it was way down
and so uh and then we've developed these
properties
right the the that our offices are in
and they're very expensive too so i've
got those two things that's caused mine
to be very heavy real estate
you certainly would not want to do that
if you don't want to deal with tenants
yeah and in my case we've got uh
rachel's husband winston as you know
runs all of our uh
property management and our development
and all that and so
i'm blessed that i have winston and a
company
that manages a real estate company that
does that for me day to day so that
takes a lot of hassle off of me
personally
yeah uh i'm not over trying to make sure
the heat and air is getting fixed on a
house or something i'm not
because i got to run this place and so
but anyway all that to say
that when you're first starting you know
you you can
you can change the ratio back and forth
you could get into real estate and go i
don't like it
yeah and move back towards mutual funds
or vice versa let's talk about this real
state things i'm thinking there's
probably people listening right now that
they may be in that spot where they are
ready
they've maxed everything out and they
want to get into real estate they've
never done it before other than their
own home that they've paid off
and they're looking to save up and pay
cash for their first piece of real
estate do you have any advice for them
like hey you've got to do this
you're just getting into it here's what
you need to know from someone who's done
it
um things to look out for that type of
thing
yeah the cheaper the property
the better the rate of return typically
is
and the higher the hassle factor
interesting so you can buy
lower income stuff in that end of town
that uh that your roi your math on it is
really sweet okay but your roi on your
time is not
quite the opposite yeah so on the other
end of the spectrum
is like uh credit commercial real estate
so if you've got a
a a household name as a tenant or let's
even go further the post office
wants you to do a build a suit on a
commercial so the post office is your
tenant the federal government right well
that's kind of like automatic right
you're going to get your check right you
don't have to worry about the
collections
and it's a 50-year lease it's kind of
just becomes
you just go the mailbox open it there it
is in your mo there's your money
uh but your rate of return is way down
there they don't give much of a cap rate
much of a rate of return on that
so like a walgreens there's a lot of
walgreens walgreens doesn't uh buy those
properties
they do build a suits and they get
investors and but walgreens is a credit
tenant
meaning that they're uh you can actually
take that contract to the bank and
borrow against it it's that strong
wow and so but on that end of the
spectrum that's the
least hassle and so kind of in the
middle is like just regular offices or
apartments and then on down a little bit
it's just a nice
single-family home you're not going to
make as much on that but you also are
dealing with a little different
class a person typically and how you're
how they're how you're going to interact
with them and the hassle factor goes
down so that's thing one
thing two would be um your money is made
at the buy
and what happens on almost all of us
including me
on our very first investment property we
get really excited
yeah about being an investor yeah and
you pay too much
you pay too much you should always buy
investment properties at a discount
you should never pay appraisal ever okay
and in a market like today
that sidelines you right it's very
different you don't have a chance it's
very difficult to find deals today it's
quite the opposite of 2008
and so but but if you buy a 200 000
property for 200 000
is a little tougher to get your roi on
it but if you can pick up that 200 000
property for 150 now you got that
built-in 50 to start with
and you're gonna always not only have
the appreciation but then your rents
on you're ready to return on that 150
because your rents aren't based on what
you paid for they're based on what it's
worth
right right right that makes sense 200
house rents for the same
whether you've got a mortgage on it
whether you don't whether you paid 250
for it or whether you paid 150 for it it
still rents for the same amount
yeah and so uh your rate of return on
your rents and everything
is changed by the monies made at the buy
which requires this most difficult thing
in real estate and that's patience
yeah and you're just shopping and
shopping and you're not emotionally
involved and you're looking for a deal
we're not trying to hurt anybody's
feelings we're not trying to rip anybody
off
but i just don't put money in stuff
unless it's a deal yeah and i own
um because that's why why you're doing
it is to make money that's why you're
doing it if you remember that that's
going to help you
resist that temptation to overpay this
is a trans a mathematical transaction
right
nothing else right but there's something
about real estate that's just very
emotional
yeah for all of us and uh even if you're
not gonna live there the first house i
flipped i made 800 bucks on
well translation i almost lost money
yeah yeah
yeah if i hadn't crawled around under
the stinking house and put the pipes in
myself
yeah i would have lost my lost money so
i didn't even make my labor back
yeah you know i probably made a buck an
hour on working on the stupid thing
right
on my labor and didn't make a dime as an
investor so that's unwise yeah but i was
all excited i had to buy it
and i thought it was it was a hud
foreclosure
i thought uh because it said foreclosure
on it it meant deal
um i didn't think that but something in
my emotions said
justice it justified it it's gotta have
some i gotta work on it sorry i need
some ways to fix it up it's
sir it's a fixer-upper but i pace
thinking obviously full price for it
almost
yeah uh because it took 90 days to sell
the stinking thing it didn't sell super
fast
and i had to work on it and i barely got
out even with my own labor in it for
free
yeah so that's all about i was excited
to be a real estate member now granted i
was 21 years old
but but still that's the mistake that
beginners make
yeah that's a good discussion good
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
james childs is in the booth running the
show kelly daniels is running the show
and letting
james think he is she's the associate
producer
i'm dave ramsey and we'll be back
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
christy wright ramsay personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five her new book is on pre-sale
take back your time the guilt-free
guide to life balance she will be doing
a
free live event streamed
tonight at 7 pm central time on youtube
and facebook
all about balance you'll learn what life
balance is what it isn't the root cause
of why you feel
out of balance and how to achieve your
version
of balance ramsay solutions dot com
slash balance christie is an incredible
communicator you will thoroughly enjoy
this event and by the way did i mention
it's
free so tonight 7 p.m
central time youtube and facebook ramsay
solutions.com
ballots get your rsvp and it's going to
be fun it's going to be good it's going
to help you know not only what's keeping
you from feeling balanced but what to do
about it it's going to be great
jose is with us in detroit hey jose
what's up
hello joe's joe's hello
oh there he is there he is we found the
phone good what's up man
sorry about that it was on you no
troubles how can we help
um so i'm looking to go back to grad
school and i'm kind of curious as to
whether i should be taking out the
student loans to do so
well jos do you listen to the show very
much not very much my brother's the one
that actually took me on to the show
recently
he tricked you he did well i'm glad
you're here
brother said step up on this trap
and we're going to pull the rug out call
that
he said call this guy that hates debt
and ask him if you should take out debt
he's
he's got some popcorn listing this call
right now jose listen
no we don't want you to take out student
loans not for
a master's degree not for any degree we
want you to save up and pay cash what do
you want to do
what do you want to get your degree in
cyber security okay what are you doing
now
uh so i actually was working in i.t i
actually recently quit my job
uh but so right now i'm not doing
anything but i
was working in it for a state agency
okay so why do you need a master's in
cyber security to work in cyber security
we got cyber security people working
here
none of them have even a four-year
degree in it
um i don't know if you necessarily need
one so i didn't go to school
because there are lots of people with
cybersecurity degrees who have made it
happen
um i didn't go to school for any of this
all this kind of just like fell in my
lap and i kind of worked it out
through work as i was doing it and
i want to i want to be really really
good at what i do and so
i there's lots of knowledge that i don't
have in my years there have been things
that have come up just because i didn't
have that
but i learned from google uh when there
are things that'll
come up missing so i'm just kind of
looking to go to school for them to
actually teach me the things that i need
to know and then
and then go into the field that is very
wise
you're very smart in what you have
described
um as a person who has a thousand people
working for me
440 of them are technology people
many of them in cyber security our cyber
security guys were at work last night as
a matter of fact had an issue
and um so uh in other words i'm the
employer
that you want to hire you later in a
sense you follow me
so coming from that perspective i'm am
qualified to tell you
i would not require that you have a
master's degree as a matter of fact i'm
pretty sure
getting a master's degree in information
technology will not
teach you what you're trying to get
instead
you are already on the right track and
in practical experience is what i'd be
looking for number one
number two i would want you to pick up
some of the trade
certificates certification programs like
microsoft certs and some of those others
and there's plenty of really good
one-off training
in cyber security that would actually
give you the information that you are
looking for
the knowledge that you are looking for
to be able to do the thing that you're
wanting to do
versus a master's degree is very
academic
and honestly by the time you finish it
the stuff you learned will probably be
obsolete
it's gonna be dated that's right jose
i'm curious why'd you quit your job
because i wanted to go to school um
so i was kind of feeling stuck at work
for a little bit and
i decided that i wanted to make the
career change
okay um but wasn't quite sure how to get
into it
uh so then school looked like to be a
good option and i actually got into
one of the best cyber security schools
in the country and um
i want to get into what's the product so
i want to be the carnegie mellon
what's it called uh carnegie mellon what
does it cost
oh what does it cost sorry i think what
it's called a hundred thousand dollars
okay i would not spend that
okay i really wouldn't i mean you can do
what you want to do you you
but you and you obviously called some
people you hardly know who we are and
we're
we're screwing with your dreams so it's
hard for you to hear all this but i'm
just telling you as
as the employer that i mean with a
thousand person team here
400 tech people on the team i couldn't
give a rip
less if you went to carnegie mellon or
not just let me tell you here's what
here's what i would do
instead if i were you and it's going to
still move you in the direction you want
to go
i would find a company that you want to
do cyber security for
i would go take a pay cut yep and do
anything for them
and study under them and learn how to do
the things you don't know how to do
while on the job while getting paid
which is still going to pay you more
than you're making now which is nothing
better than that they will also pay
tuition and you're not in a hundred
thousand dollars
not to carnegie mellon they'll just pay
you tuition to go get the search that'll
give you the knowledge that you need to
do the job you're looking to go do
so we just saved you a hundred thousand
dollars in debt and you have an income
while learning how to do the things you
want to do you just signed up for
harvard
is what you signed up for and the
question is
is there an roi when you pay full price
for harvard
and the answer is in such a small
percentage of jobs will you make a
return on investment on this
that it is not a good investment if you
were my son
i would advise you the exact way we are
advising you right now
and uh that's not to trash carnegie
mellon it's to say
that in the field that you're in the
rate of change of
information is daily it's
daily while you're getting this degree
some of the languages and code that you
know right now will become obsolete
while you're getting this degree the
processes
some of the companies that provide
security
apps and provide security software will
be out of business
while you're getting this degree it's
the rate of change
is blinding in the technology world
you have to be in a dead sprint to keep
up with it when it is your career
but if you sideline yourself and go into
crunchy academic world
while you're doing this i'm i mean and
it's not to say that carnegie mellon
isn't cutting edge i suspect they are
you some of you people are gonna
troll me on this just troll your butt
away i'm the one that'll be hiring you
the
here's the thing joe's you know who
people want to hire people they know
that they've seen do the job on the job
not someone that has a certificate with
a certain brand on it
someone they've worked with someone they
trust they've watched them go be that
person
if you had a hundred thousand cash in
the bank i tell you not to do it if
you're borrowing money i'm going to yell
at you for doing it
don't do it son now you go do what you
want to do
and you can call us later and we'll
still love you and we'll still help you
even if you do stupid stuff this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everything about how much money you
would have if you didn't give it all to
some bank or car company in the form of
payments
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income
what if you got your whole income back
instead of giving it to someone else by
getting out of debt
fire sally may kick her out of the house
get rid of your lexus motor credit
payments what would your life look like
it's possible and it doesn't have to
take as long as you think
it all starts with financial peace
university the class that's helped
nearly six million people
learn the proven plan to get out of debt
and become wealthy
but it's not just enough to learn the
plan you gotta actually freaking do it
and the way you do it is starting with
the budgeting app the world's best
budgeting app that's every dollar and
every dollar premium is part of the
whole package and
all of this you access it through ramsey
plus a ramsey plus membership
you can create the life where your money
actually works for you
instead of you just working for it time
to get rid of the debt
for good start your free trial of ramsey
plus
text trial to 33 789
that's trial two three three seven
eight nine hannah is with us in
myrtle beach hi hannah welcome to the
ramsey show
hello dave and christy i'm excited and
terrified to talk to y'all
oh don't be terrified how can we help
what's going on right now
um i'm looking for a little bit of
advice my husband and i
are getting out of debt for our third
time
in our marriage and i can never seem to
get past
baby step three i can never seem to save
the emergency fund
my husband is a full-time pastor a
full-time roofer
and so he works all the time so i take
care of the finances i take care of the
budget
everything my question is um
how can i have him help me when it comes
to the budget and the finances and
everything
he's willing to help but he doesn't know
how to help
um he also does not spend any money
whatsoever so he's an extreme
favor i'm the spender so i'm just
looking for a little bit of advice to
get us
onto baby step 3 and past baby step 3.
i'm so tired of feeling like i'm doing
it by myself
hmm i know this is not what you're
asking hannah but i want to go back to
why you
get yourself back into debt three
different times what's going on
why do you keep going back into this
thing it is
it is me just losing all
power and will to not get back into that
um i get i get past baby step two
and it's not huge that like i'm not i'm
not in big debt right now but it's
sorry i'm very nervous that's okay
your husband's dad was a roofer
no no my husband is a roofer what was
your husband's dad do
um he right now
he's working at a plant what was it what
did he do when your husband was growing
up
um he worked in a chemical plant okay in
a factory
okay all right um
your husband is a good man he loves god
he works and he works hard he however
is not functioning like your husband
he's functioning like your son
right you're the mommy and you make all
the adult decisions and carry all the
adult
responsibilities he just goes to work
and if you actually gently call him out
on that
he will respond because he loves his
wife
and that would sound like this honey i
need your help
i can't carry the weight of all of this
by myself anymore number one i can't
handle the stress
number two when i do it by myself we go
back into that
and you work so hard you're such a good
man
but i've got to have you emotionally
carry
your half of the finances of this
household
and here's one thing i would add a way
of saying man up
here's one thing i would add when you
have this conversation
when you have this conversation which is
is going to be so important
i want you to be extremely specific
with what help looks like to you yes
because if you say help me and he says
okay i'll help you and then
six months goes by in your mind help is
it more overtime
yeah you need to be very like even when
you say i need help i don't even know
that you know this will be good for you
to think about okay here's what this
would look like does it look like paying
bills does it look like showing up for
the budget meeting
what does it look like specifically
tactically
visually and then connect there and
allow him to speak into it obviously
but expectations have got to be crystal
clear i'm not making any more financial
decisions
by myself there you go there's a there's
a great one you have to help me make the
financial decisions we're going to look
at the budget together
and you're going to feel the strain of
the bill paying with me
yeah yeah because you feel the weight
when the stuff is
when it gets tight you get the you get
the sweat in the palm of your hands and
across the top of your eyebrow
you get that feeling that tightness in
your throat
he doesn't have that feeling at all he
needs that feeling
it will change and it will help you
because the good news is he's a saver
and so he's going to hold you
accountable now the bad news is
he's going to hold you accountable so
your your days of being in control by
yourself are about done
yeah yeah you're going to be careful
with what you wished for because your
customer with all this spending and
going back into debt but it's going to
be a great thing it's going to be such a
healthy
conversation where you're on the same
page let's do it he's meeting you there
let's do it this way i'm going to put
you in rmz plus for a year
free as my gift and and the way you can
phrase the conversation then is honey
i need your help i can't do this by
myself anymore it's wearing me out i
need you to help me carry the weight
of the adult decision making of the
money i've been doing it by myself
and i just can't do it anymore i've got
to have you help me do that and the way
we're going to start that is we're going
to go through this class together
right here online we'll sit on the couch
and do it after the kids go to bed
and i know you're tired so am i i'm sick
and tired though and so you've got to
help me with this
and just like if you came to him and
said honey i'm sick i need you to put
the kids to bed
he would do that he would do that
he would carry his share of the weight
he would do chores that he normally
doesn't
do if you asked him for help because he
loves you
but you need to be very specific because
guys we don't do subtlety
you have to tell us what it is and then
say it again a couple more hundred times
if you get him in this class together
and you guys are making the budget
together on every dollar and you're
making your decisions together
it's gonna give you what you want and
some things you didn't even want that
are coming your way
but you're gonna it's gonna change the
whole thing so that'll be a way you can
do it so you hold on and i'll
pick up uh i'll have i'll pick up i'll
have kelly pick up
and get you signed up for ramsey plus
and you can you can do the stuff you're
supposed to do then and you guys get in
there and
and get into financial peace university
get the every dollar budget going
together
because this is what's going on so
christy there's a thing
and you guys out there listening i'm
gonna piss some of you off but just get
ready i'm not it's not it doesn't come
from a mean place
it's observation and it's not always
true but in a lot of
blue-collar families mama takes care of
the money
and daddy does the work and that's a
modeling thing of what it means to be a
husband
that he got from his dad and so he moved
in
and now mama's taking care of the money
and but there's a
um in in oftentimes in in white collar
families it can be the same way if you
grew up in a blue-collar family because
the generation on what's taught
exactly what how it's taught to you
who's this is what you do
now you know in your case you grew up a
single mom's household
where she's making all the decisions and
so you would never even think of
not being involved in the decisions in
your household right it wouldn't occur
to you because of your upbringing
it's interesting though because matt and
i have had such interesting discussions
as newlyweds and still present day of
how we as a generation but also
as a couple do things different than our
parents did not only because of how they
worked
but even just uh raising kids and
expectations it all is different we have
to define it for ourselves what that's
going to look like
and you but and you do you do have to
clarify these where these roles came
from
rachel does a good job with that in the
know yourself know your money book and
the know yourself
money assessment for couples that's
another thing you can do is jump into
that because that gets into the
family of origin what how family how
money was handled in the household you
grew up in because that affects then how
you're
communicating with your spouse about it
yep so you could take that know yourself
money assessment for couples y'all you
guys a bunch of you ought to take it
uh you can get it at ramsey solutions in
the store it's inexpensive and it's
really really a powerful assessment
it'll open up things for you like cray
cray man it's nuts it's it'll blow your
mind
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
on the debt-free stage in the lobby of
ramsey solutions
andrew and amy are with us hey guys how
are you
good good welcome where do you guys live
fredericksburg virginia
oh wow nice drive down to nashville yep
our flight or whatever
we drove yeah good to have you and how
much debt have you two paid off
uh 247 352.98
whoa how long did this take seven years
four months
all right and your range of income
during that time i started around 100
000 and up to around 170. man
so i've got a feeling based on those
numbers the number of amount of time and
the number of dollars that
you might have paid off your house yep
we did i'm looking at weird people
way to go 100 debt-free house and
everything
yep how old are you guys uh i'm 34. i'm
35.
you're 34 years old with a paid four
house in fredericksburg yep
that's awesome what's this house worth
uh probably close to 280 300 now
that's amazing wow you're so weird
you are so freaking weird i love you
that's awesome man thank you yeah you're
too young and pretty to be 100 debt free
now y'all are amazing this is just
amazing well done what put you on this
journey seven years
ago uh well um we actually met
um and and i had already paid off my
debt uh before student loans paid those
off bought my house
um and then we met and amy had some
loans so we went right back at it
um and before we got married we
disagreed we're going to do this
so she actually started before before we
got married
she was already on it and then when we
got married we
cash flowed our wedding how long you
been married six
six years a couple weeks ago okay so you
you had the house for seven
then that's where the 7.4 comes from
seven years or four months
but the whole time y'all been married
this whole six years you've been
knocking on the house knocking on her
student loans and then knocking on the
house yep
yeah we paid our student loans off in
2017 and then uh we
cash flowed a couple of upgrades to our
house a new kitchen
um we needed a bigger car sure we
started having kids so we had to
have to get a new car cash flow to all
that stuff and then i went right back
into the house
so what in the world why why does a
young guy henry i'm sorry uh
andrew amy you marry this guy and the
first thing he starts talking about is
how quick we're gonna get out of that
right like like that that's a real
romantic conversation
and it happened pretty quickly it was
just like student loans need to be taken
care of
um and kind of task oriented didn't he
yeah oh very much
so amy was this it was this a new
concept for you like when he's talking
about paying off the student loans
paying off the house is this like
okay what are you talking about or were
you already kind of like familiar with
dave and being debt free and all that
not familiar with dave i knew i wanted
to
pay off my student loans but yeah it was
yeah
so it was just a process um i was
just 100 jumping on board i was i grew
up with you'll always have a mortgage
you'll always have a car payment
and i was okay with that but after we
just
or like we don't want to live that way
yeah he changed andrew
where did you learn this whole thing i
was actually trying to think about what
the first time i heard
heard of you was and i can't remember um
but i just i know every day going to
work
coming back i listened to the podcast
every single day
driving in driving back and then i tell
her hey i heard this on the show hey
let's listen to this one so we would
listen to
little snippets all the time so it was
kind of always on
it's just always on my mind in the
background of your life it's amazing how
motivating it can be
when you're on the journey to listen to
people doing their debt-free screen or
just listen to the advice the answers
that keeps you motivated because the
journey can be long but you all did it
it was
very long and that was definitely a key
thing was just listening in and hearing
other people doing their scream and
knowing one day
one day that'll be us that's cool
okay you're 35 years old you have a paid
for house
make 170. what do you guys do for a
living
i get to stay home with my babies i love
it
awesome yeah and i do uh software
project management
yeah excellent excellent very good
okay um what is the secret
you hear me ask this all the time yeah
what is the thing you have to do if you
want to be
you when you grow up i mean if you want
to be debt-free house and everything and
you're 35 years old or 45 years old 55
years old what's the secret to getting
out of debt
i think the secret is really just paying
attention um i know for a while i just
you know making money not really knowing
where things are going and then once i
just said all right well before i even
set a goal
let me just see what i'm doing what am i
spending my money on
so actively tracking it um actively
sitting down doing the budget
um talking about it even though it's you
know sometimes painful to really
try to think about it and have those
conversations but really open honest
communication i think
it was it was difficult for me it was
very difficult to sit down
every month to have that budget talk but
seeing the spreadsheets that he made and
we had it taped on the bathroom door
and filling out the depth thermometer
and we had like a little game to pay off
our house
just seeing that it was that was it
that made it worth facing what because
really doing that budget meetings like
looking in the mirror
it's like and you don't always like what
you see you know it's like
you know i got to deal with this every
month and that's that's what the dread
is isn't it
yes to say i got i got to deal with me i
got to deal with what's going on and
and because i know i'm going to push
this against this goal that we're
sharing
and i do want the goal but i don't
always want to do what it takes to get
to the goal right well and good for you
guys for doing that for having that look
at the mirror for
for facing it every single month because
i think that moment you're describing
is the thing so many people avoid and
because they avoid it they never get to
your shoes they never make the change
but simply having the courage
to face it and then do something about
it
that i mean that's what kept you on this
path i mean you guys are amazing that's
the right word courage
yeah that's the right word christy
that's exactly right way to go you guys
you're freaking heroes it's amazing who
were your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
uh my family my parents came with us it
wasn't just my family but our family
just they were always behind us always
asking you know
came down to cheer you on an excuse to
hang out with the grandkids
oh yeah yeah i love it very cool way to
go mom and dad
good stuff and the kiddos are with you
what are their names and ages
uh we've got henry he's five uh eleanor
she's three
and already he's one way to go already
here you got this man
i love it well we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because for sure
that's your next chapter to completely
change this beautiful family tree a
whole new direction because of you guys
and um so how much are your investments
have you
already added all those up uh yeah we
have um i think last time we looked our
net worth probably around 700 now
so you're on your way to baby steps a
millionaire oh yeah be there in no time
we'll be back
you'll be there you'll be there by the
time you're 40. easy hope so easy
easy way to go there it is that's how it
works right there people
you're watching it happen in real time
wow
amazing good stuff also a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away to somebody and start their journey
and uh just disrupt their whole american
life
not a bad thing to do at all i love it
all right amy
and andrew henry eleanor and artie 247
000 paid off in seven years and four
months
house and everything you're looking at
and listening to
weird people making 100 to 170 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one free
[Applause]
yeah baby that's how it happens right
there
how fun is that those kids don't even
know they don't even know what their
parents have just done for them
i mean that's incredible that's a
complete change yeah they're young
enough that
they they may have some vague memory of
this weird day but
uh that dad and mom uh they busted the
whole thing
busted the whole thing it's completely
changed because when you're 35 years old
you don't have a house payment you
understand how much money you're going
to have
that's tens of millions of dollars if
you just invest the house payment
for the next 30 years yeah 35 to 65 put
2 000 bucks in a month in a calculator
and see what it does for you it'll blow
your freaking mind
i mean it's tens of millions of dollars
because they're gonna be millionaires
probably i said five years it won't take
that long probably take two
yeah before they break through that
because the house is going to continue
to go up in value the current
investments are going to go up in value
and they're going to be adding to them
yeah
so they'll be baby steps millionaires
well before they're 40.
and uh and being a millionaire doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter what matters is you
took control of your life the
millionaire is just a scorecard
and it gives you the options to be
generous the options to do things
those three kids will never know debt
they'll never know student loan debt
yeah
they'll never know car debt they'll
never know house debt unless they
misbehave
and don't do what their parents taught
them yeah wow
pretty cool stuff touchdown baby
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
miss measure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time you save even more use the
promo code ramsay
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from lissa in new york
she writes i recently left my career as
a management consultant and am
considering a couple different options
to create my own business
i have forty two thousand dollars in
credit card debt but i have forty five
thousand in cash on hand to pay it off
what should i do
pay off all my debt and hope to get a
business loan later or use my savings to
begin the business opportunities that
will generate
an ongoing income stream within six
months well we don't have to know all
the details of this to say of course we
don't want you to take out business debt
business loans are just like personal
loans in the fact that they're debt and
they're bad
and they're a risk and they're yours and
you have to be the one to pay them so we
don't
recommend that ever the good news is uh
lissa you have savings
to be able to pay off that debt and
become debt free you'll still have three
thousand dollars
in cash on hand to start your uh
emergency fund your fully funded
emergency fund which will be three to
six months of expenses and then you save
up to
cash flow whatever business growth or
startup costs you may need the thing
that i would challenge if i
had lissa on the phone when i would ask
what is your business
and what cost do you really have because
a lot of times dave i get this kind of
question and people think oh i
need fifty thousand dollars to start my
business i need
ten thousand dollars on my business and
you don't you don't in many industries
you don't some you might need some
startup costs but in many of them you
can start with your
baby version of your idea your scrappy
version of your idea
and as the business is validated and you
get cash into the business
that cash can fund the growth you
started this this organization on a card
table in your living room
yeah and i we don't know what her
business is she was a management
consultant before and if you're going
into consulting you don't need much
money you need
yeah you need a computer and some
consulting gigs
it's your it's your services you're
charging for there that's the thing so
you don't have to have a lot
now so i completely agree with christy
and it'd be ridiculous to pass the
credit card debt tour and take about
business loans that's just trading
that's just a dog chasing his tail
you're just trading one for the other
you're just you're
you're kidding yourself you didn't
really do anything you just swapped
hands
um so what i what i would the only thing
i
might consider but you'd have to make a
really tough case for it
and i would argue with you i'll warn you
ahead of time that let's say you had a
business
and you said all right i need ten
thousand dollars worth of
equipment there's no possible way
not just to be optimal but there's no
possible way to start without
some inventory some equipment something
and uh out of forty thousand
and you could show me how you can make
ten thousand back
in two months yep as and i
and you have to make me believe you and
believe me i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna push you hard on it okay
because it's what i would do if somebody
worked for me came in here and said i
want to spend ten thousand
and um i would say okay where are we
gonna make that money back because
that's the whole idea of business is if
you're gonna spend money
but putting ten thousand dollars on a
five-year payout
and calling that a business that's dumb
that's just dumb
so you would need an almost
instantaneous break even to sell me on
that idea
but if you could do that i would say pay
off the top 32
000 of your debt snowball put 10 000 in
the business and then two months later
you're debt-free yeah
that would be okay but but you'd have to
really prove it
and it's not i want to open my business
and this is optimal
i mean it's like you have a computer i
want a better computer that's that's you
don't need that you don't have to do
that i want to be a photographer and i
already have a camera but i want a
better camera
no no this is what i spend my life
around ramsay doing all the time if
somebody wants to do something i said
we'll make something with what we've got
right we have all these things and well
it'd be optimal i know it'd be optimal
but we you know
optimal doesn't equal profit optimal
equals spending money
yeah and when you spend money it lowers
your profit this is a
business equation here people so really
really good
question you've got we don't have the
nuance in the details of your situation
but
the the concept being here no debt
know-how no way start something
and you are the secret sauce not the
crap you would buy with some of this
money
i got a question dave you've been
talking about no debt for over 30 years
and you still regularly get questions
should i take out this loan
it's not just new people either it's not
just people that like it's their first
time calling in first time listening to
the show
do you think that they think they're
gonna get a different answer no
no they they want someone to say it out
loud for them okay if they're it now she
could be new
sure i mean she could have just joined
us on youtube a month ago or sure that's
possible
but the number of people that calling
i've listened here for five years and
i'm thinking about getting a car loan
you know and we're like no no you really
weren't listening were you
but we want to be snarky and sometimes
we are but uh
but but overall but what happens is is
that they were listening and all this
stuff kind of worked over here
and then they had this new situation and
it's different it feels like
it's different it's different or i
really know i shouldn't do it but it's
like i'm going to let those people on
ramsay show be my conscience so speak
they're going to speak into my head the
little angel on my shoulder going
don't do it right where all the devils
are out there in the world going ah
yeah it's no big deal to borrow money
and get the airline miles on your credit
card and all that bull crap you know
yeah and so that that's um but you know
we get to be the angel on the shoulder
sometimes
but but um yeah it is as if
we were inconsistent or something yeah
we're not we get it all the time
always get the same answer dan is with
us dan's in scranton pennsylvania hi dan
what's up
hi dave how are you today better than we
deserve what's up
all right great there's a bucket list
item to check off for me
my my wife and i have been on baby step
two for one year
we started the plan last july with a
hundred and six thousand dollars in debt
making eighty nine thousand not
including our first or second mortgage
uh at the time our first mortgage was
thirty thousand and our second one was
fifty thousand
by those standards you teach us to put
the second mortgage into baby step six
um so fast forward to now
we now make about a hundred and twenty
thousand a year and we're over halfway
through baby step two with about forty
seven thousand dollars left
um the second mortgage is down to forty
four thousand
which now would have us put our second
mortgage in baby step two
do we recalibrate things there because
if the second mortgage is in baby step
two now
now we still have ninety one thousand
dollars in baby step two instead of the
forty seven
interesting uh and only nine thousand on
our initial mortgage so that should be
paid off by may of 2023
sometimes the way to answer the detailed
nuance to a wicked weird scenario which
this is
is to pan back to the principle that
caused us to put the step in place in
the first place
kind of like dave do i tithe on this
little thingy over here
well let's pan back and say the whole
reason for tithing is giving
and god wants to teach us to be generous
he's trying to change our character and
turn us into givers
let's start with that as the principle
and then we can figure out if this
little nuanced corner of this tithing
question
just give you know just give your god's
not gonna be mad at you just give
and so in this case we're gonna pan back
and not be quite that snarky because i
like the question it's very interesting
it's an evolving situation fluid
situation
so i'm a pan back and say okay why did
we say
that if your second mortgage is more
than half your annual income push it to
six
the reason we babysit six the reason we
said that was
it's gonna take too long
you're gonna be stuck in baby step two
if you make a hundred thousand and you
have a two hundred thousand dollar
second mortgage
you're gonna be stuck in baby step two
forever
okay so we pushed it to six and said you
probably want to refinance your first
and second roll them together
and then you've got a plan to get your
home paid off
but you've got this monster but but if
you got a tiny little second mortgage
trade it like a credit card debt and get
let's get you know it's a mosquito let's
smack it get it done
and in there so your situation has
changed
which changed the equation and said now
it's under half
the reason we said this was it's going
to take too long and so the way we
answer the question is
if we put it in baby step 2 now because
your situation has evolved
is it going to take too long then you
can answer the question
and i don't care which one you do either
one's okay you can put it in six
yeah you can do it now the trick is
don't get stuck in two
so long that you quit give up and don't
get don't finish or get out of debt plan
if you need to leave it over in six and
roll it into a new first mortgage fine
fine if you can stick it over there and
punch it in the head be done with it
that'd be awesome too
but the whole concept was don't let it
take too long
good good question christy good show
thanks so much thanks for having me
christy wright
you can hear her tonight at 7 pm go to
ramseysolutions.com and get your tickets
this is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermsyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice welcome
to an
everyday millionaire theme hour
what is an everyday millionaire theme
hour we're going to talk only to people
that have a
net worth of 1 million or greater
[Music]
why are we going to do that because if
you want to be wealthy the best thing
you can do
is find out what wealthy people do and
do it
not what someone with a theory has not
with a broke finance professor with
tenure and what he thinks
not what your broke brother-in-law
thinks with his political opinions at
thanksgiving
but what do really wealthy people do
see broke people sitting around and
talking about being wealthy
is like a bunch of fat people sitting
around talking about being in in the
olympics
it's not gonna happen okay and
you know this we're all in that same
boat we have to figure out if you've
been divorced 14 times
i hope this new marriage works for you
but i'm not reading your book on
marriage
you're what's known as a failure i'm not
doing it
i hope this one works i love you you can
be my friend
but i don't need your i don't want to
follow what you've been doing because
it's not
had a good track record darling you know
and so what we want to do is we want to
talk to not people with political
agendas
not people with the news talking heads
with a with some 26 year old wrote the
script for him and they're reading it
out of a camera we're going to talk to
real human beings who have a net worth
of a million dollars or more and find
out how they did it
so then you can decide if you want to do
it well a million dollars isn't much
money anymore dave
you're right but it's more than not
having a million dollars
considerable more well dave millionaires
are all
they're all what you really think you
know what you're talking about
maybe you need to listen to this hour if
you have a one million dollar or greater
net worth your net worth is what you own
minus what you owe your assets minus
your liabilities is your net worth
it is not a feeling it is not a moral
discussion it is a mathematical
fact it's not a million dollars worth of
income
there are lots of people that make a
million dollars a year and don't have
nothing because they spend two million
dollars a year
and they're called congress right so i
mean this is this is what you've got to
do right you
have to figure out what a real
millionaire is
and then go and that's the at least the
first wealth target
now later if you want to get a jet you
could be a billionaire
later if you want to have seven cars you
could be a billionaire
later if you want six houses you could
be a billionaire but millionaires are
none of those things
millionaires typically drive used cars
they're steady
with their investing they did not
inherit their money
they're not evil rich people who stole
and beat up the little man
and took his money out of took his
welfare check out of his hand and ran
off with a cackle
like a cartoon or something this is
not real people this is crap you hear
from broke people
that have wrong impressions about people
that have built wealth so let's talk to
some real ones
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five david and kristen are
starting us off from dallas texas
what's you guys net worth
dave it's about 1.8 million dollars cool
give me a little breakdown on that by
category how much in
retirement how much in-house and so on
it's about 50 retirement funds 25
real estate and 25 other accounts
so about 500 in real estate about 900
in uh retirement
and about 400 in miscellaneous
right okay did i do that right that's
right
okay how old are you guys
we are both 52. cool and
how much of this 1.8 million did you
inherit
no money just a few small family items
but your net worth did not come from
well
wealth given to you by family members
no actually we inherited about five
thousand dollars when my grandmother
died and i think as soon as that money
hit the bank account
uh one of our air conditioners went out
and we had to replace it for about forty
eight hundred dollars
gotcha so as a household income what has
been your
worst year financially income that when
you like when you started or something
and your best your
income
well when we first got married i think
we had a combined income of about forty
five thousand dollars
now we make about 180 to 220
depending on bonuses okay what do you
guys do for a living
i am an engineer who works as a sales
manager
and kristin teaches high school english
and yearbook
ah very good so christian your degrees
in education i assume
it's in english in english okay and uh
then david you're an engineer you said
right
that's right i have a bachelor's in
mechanical engineering
and then i went back to school and got
an mba okay cool what were your gpas
well mine was 3.7
overall and 3.9 in english okay
i was a b student in engineering and in
business school my gpa was about 3.9
yeah you were an adult student by then
yeah
okay cool good good very good
okay so how much of this debt is here
because you used
borrowed money to create wealth
probably zero i don't think i ever went
on margin to make an investment or
anything
okay so you have nine hundred thousand
in almost a million in your retirement
alone
uh which by the way this is textbook
case study right here you guys
you hit all the numbers almost identical
to the averages
uh the typical millionaire is 51 years
old uh the typical millionaire has
one third of their income or of their
net worth
in their house i mean you guys are just
right down the line and
so the the investing that you've done
into retirement do you feel like you've
gotten good rates of return
excellent rates of return or poor rates
of return
i mostly invest in index funds
usually s p 500 index funds so we
usually get
market rates of return right okay so
medium medium to good
okay good good okay um
are you guys uh book people or tv people
do you read or you watch tv
kristin is definitely the book person
yeah uh the english teacher that makes
sense
okay um very interesting okay
quickly what would be that you both i
read about a book a week but um
uh dave watches tv more i only get to
watch tv during the summers
okay uh what
would they be the advice you two would
have for the 25 year old couple
that's listening that's just like you
were
can they get there
well i think financially we've done most
things right
what i would advise the younger me to do
would be to pay more attention to our
day-to-day finances
it's it's easy to tell yourself that
you're busy with work or kids or life
and not have your eye on the ball and
there have
been a couple of instances where we
weren't paying close attention to our
finances and it sort of cost us
yeah i understand way to go you guys i'm
so proud of you
congratulations first generation
millionaires
every day millionaires it's an everyday
millionaire theme hour
if you have a net worth of a million
dollars a greater no matter how you got
it
call and tell us your story the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
if you have a net worth of one million
dollars or greater we want to talk to
you this hour
so you can explain how it is you did
that
because other people might want to do it
well dave all rich people are evil
you know what that's ridiculous
there are evil people in every category
black white skinny fat
old young southern
northerner southerner northerner
rich and poor there are jerks and evil
people in
every category and there are vast
majority of people
are not the vast majority of people are
great people
in any category in any demographic
so for you to ascribe wealth only to
wealthy people does not say anything
about the facts
it says something about you
it says who you are it says how you have
a toxic warped view of the world
you're bitter jealous and angry
it doesn't mean that what you said or
even believe
is the truth so that's ridiculous
everyone inherited their wealth no
some did and they didn't do anything
wrong when they did that by the way
i thoroughly encourage you to build some
wealth and leave it to your children i
hope you can each of you
listening can make your children
millionaires wouldn't that be neat
if you taught them how to have the
character to handle it and be generous
to others as a part of the equation
wouldn't that be a neat thing so i
encourage you to create millionaires
through inheritance that's fine i'm not
mad about that
but this idea that the only way you can
become wealthy is through an inheritance
is a statement that says that the little
man can't get ahead
and that's statistically factually not
true we did the largest
study with ramsey research in
conjunction with another research team
airtight research techniques the
controls
the statistical factors were dialed in
airtight because we knew some of you
people
bitching moan and wine about this study
and so we knew we had to have it right
it's completely dialed in we studied
over 10 000 actual real millionaires
79 inherited zero
five percent inherited a very small
amount like our last caller got five
thousand dollars that did not make them
a millionaire
another five percent inherited
substantial money
after they were already millionaires
so your causation from a research
perspective from a statistical analysis
perspective
what causes people to be millionaires 89
of them did not become millionaires
that's all of them did not become
millionaires
because of an inheritance so when you
little
piss ants out there with your liberal
theologies
running around your liberal p political
stance run around
telling everybody that the only way you
can become wealthy is to inherit it
you're statistically a [ __ ]
was i unclear i hope not
i hope not i hope because it just pisses
me off because what you're doing is
you're saying that america is dead
capitalism doesn't work that the little
man can't get ahead
and the little man has a better chance
of getting ahead in america today
than in any country in any economic
system
in the history of mankind
that is a statistical fact and when you
lie
and you tell people that you that they
can't do it you are what's known
as an ignorant dream killer
pisses me off so that's why we did a
study
just to prove that you were wrong no not
really
but it's one of the side benefits which
is kind of nice so
the deal is that i don't mind if you
inherited the money i don't care if you
hit the lotto
and got it became a millionaire i'm
happy for you i'm not going to tell
people that that's the best way to do it
though because statistically
the best way to do it is the way you're
going to hear over and over and over
this hour
kevin is with us and jamie in spokane
washington hey guys what's your net
worth
right at 1 million dave good for you how
old are you guys
we are both 38. oh young ones look at
you
not even 40. ding ding all right give me
the mix on that what's the breakdown how
much retirement how much real estate so
on
so the house is right about 500.
um iras and 401k is about
460 and then the rest is a combination
of checking
emergency fund hsa and 529. did a little
cash then okay
cool good for you guys way to go how
much of this did you inherit
not a dime zero zero what's your best
working year since you started working
household income and worst working years
since you started working household
income
uh i started out at 40 and we're sitting
at right about 100 right now
good for you what do you guys do for a
living um
i'm a bridge engineer and i stay at home
with the kids
mom good for you uh so what were your
degrees in
mind bachelor science and civil
engineering
engineering obviously yeah okay and i
have a ba
in public relations excellent excellent
good what were your
gpas about 3.45
and jamie was about 3.8 ah okay
all right good for you so how much of
this wealth is there because you
borrowed money
to create wealth uh
none zero okay all right not a trick
question because everybody says you
gotta have money to make money
you know that's a great lie that's out
there because what you guys have done is
you've just done your investing
and you've got your house paid off right
exactly and we
are we wanted to say like all we've done
over the last 16 years is follow the
baby steps
and when we've stuck to them better
we've done better and we
don't stick to them as well we've slowed
down a little bit but we are
firmly baby step millionaires in our
minds for sure for sure you are
at a 38 years old i'm proud of you man
how does that feel
weird what advice would you give to a 23
year old that's listening
can they still do this absolutely
okay absolutely we i would say that um
you know we were a little less
intentional with our investing for a
while because i didn't
understand things well enough and was
afraid to make a mistake
and so learning more about
your options would be good and then also
um the closer that you follow the plan i
mean because for us
the key was following the baby steps so
closer you follow that the faster it'll
go
amen and we've never ever gone into debt
aside from
a mortgage but we um there were
definitely times
over the last decade where we've been a
little less intentional
with our purchasing choices than we
could have been and i think we could
have done this faster if we had been a
little more
intentional you are set to have uh so
much money i mean your net worth by the
time
you know you get to your 70s is probably
going to be between 10 and 20 million if
you just stay on a general track that
you're on
so that's what the math is that's what
the math says anyway so
yeah so proud of you guys well done
thanks for calling in and sharing your
story
all wealthy people are famous people
they're all athletes in the nfl or the
nba
no the last two were engineers by the
way in our study we looked at the top
five most occurring career fields
you know number one was engineer
number two accountant you know what
number three was
teacher the first couple we talked to a
minute ago
he was an engineer she was a teacher
they double whammied it right
they doubled up on it and well doctors
and lawyers
uh medical doctors didn't make the top
five
they were number six but medical doctors
mishandle money like music people
they're some of the dumbest people with
money on the planet statistically
dumb doctors are everywhere
they really are i mean they make a lot
of money
but the arrogance is just amazing in the
way they screw their money up
some of them do really good but i i deal
with them all the time so this idea that
you have to go get a medical
degree to be a millionaire is not true
and by the way lawyers barely made the
cut in the top five they were number
five
a lot of broke lawyers out there
isn't that interesting think
people think think
look at the reality that's in front of
you not the bill of goods you're being
sold on some stupid reality show that
has nothing more to do with reality
than anything on the planet even the
body parts aren't real
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and 6 gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
we are talking
to real millionaires regardless of where
their wealth came from to find out where
wealth comes from
not what some broke person's opinion is
the average
gpa of a millionaire is not 4.0 and
above
you do not have to be a genius it does
help
that you're not a doofus so i don't run
into a lot of 2.0s
the average gpa is right around 3. mine
was 2.97 and i'm still pissed off about
that 3 100 of a point
just missed it so probably beer involved
i don't know could have been
but um yeah so the average millionaire
has reasonably good intel academic
intelligence and prowess but is not
they're not savants you do not have to
be
a genius to become a millionaire you
really don't you mainly have to have
discipline
brian is in florida brian's probably
gonna prove me wrong he probably had a
4.7
brian how's your net worth
hey dave it's honor speaking with you my
net worth is
uh about 1.15 million good for you give
me a little breakdown by category please
sure it's um so i've got
iras 401k and hsas
of about 489 000
and some brokerage accounts bank
accounts
you know other savings of about 141 000
um and then real estate is a net value
of 400 and 2 000
over uh two homes okay excellent
excellent how old are you
i am 38 and my wife is 36. all right
couple young millionaires again very
very good
so how much of this 1.15 million did you
inherit
um none so i guess i have some other
like
i didn't scroll down far enough i have
some 529s and some some other accounts
and all that that adds up
so you know grandparents have put some
money into 529s but
you know that's not inheritance gonna be
maybe ten thousand dollars
okay cool so what's your best year of
household income and your worst year of
household income since you guys got
started as adults
sure um best year would be current and
and since i'm still working we'll just
say
it's over 200. um and and my wife
uh just this past february decided to
stay home with the kids
um and part of that is just you know my
pay moving up prior to 2019 um
you know we didn't make over a hundred
thousand as a household
um and i think my lowest year would have
been since we were married was probably
around 80 000 combined okay cool what do
you do for a living
i'm a commercial lender linda okay
what's your what's your did your wife do
before she's a full-time mom
um she was a marketing director for
chick-fil-a
okay excellent excellent cool all right
and uh
what are your degrees in
mine are in business through through my
mba
and uh hers is in hospitality and event
management
good okay very good and what were your
gpas
um my undergrad was you know kind of low
threes and my my mba was a 3.8 but i was
a
little older a little more mature she
was a uh
i think she was like 3.99 so she's upset
about that 0.01
yeah but got it okay all right cool
well you guys did this very quickly
congratulations you got a great start
going here
um what is your advice to someone 10 15
years younger than you
yeah i'd say you know i'd say to them
and even
the parents of those you know kind of
maybe high school age kids is
um for me i started out in banking um in
2005
at eight dollars an hour as a teller um
you know but i had tuition reimbursement
from the bank and i and i chose my
employer for that reason
you know so i was able to you know
cobble together enough funding to
you know not have student loans because
of you know
my income you know tuition reimbursement
yeah those sorts of things and
you know and i didn't do it at the
fastest pace it took me about maybe six
years to get through my undergrad
yeah um but i had no loans so you're a
math nerd like me
uh can people still do this oh
absolutely
okay good thank you for calling man
elizabeth is in tampa florida hey
elizabeth what's your net worth
hi dave um it's 1 million 87 000.
okay good for you all right cool give me
a little breakdown on that by category
like retirement real estate so forth
okay so in my retirement i have um ira
401 and a little bit in roth that's 872
000.
my emergency son i have 45
equity in my home about 145
cash on hand and checking in savings
5500
a new car fund 12 000 and a home repair
fund 7 500.
phenomenal how old are you 55
55 good for you okay and how much of
this money did you inherit
so none of that but i didn't inherit 41
000
after the passing of my mother but i put
that into my kitchen in 2019 so
it's really not included in any of those
totals
okay all right so you did in here at 41k
but definitely is not the reason that
you're a millionaire okay
and i don't know and it immediately went
into improving my home
your value the value of your home did go
up as a result so it wasn't wasted but
yeah
okay so what is uh uh what was your best
year working income and your worst year
working income
okay my best year was 157 000 my worst
year was 13 000.
what were you doing when you made 13 000
oh that was early on bank tellering
um working you know wherever i could
find a job until i worked my way up and
then um
in my 20s i got into outside sales in
the construction industry
and that's where i've been ever since
yeah and you made ding ding at that good
for you well done
so uh do you have a four-year degree no
i have a two-year associate's degree i
was working full-time and going to
school part-time at night
i graduated when i was 32 and i had a
3.87
which is probably because i was paying
for it because in high school i was no
scholar i was about a 2.0 if i was lucky
yeah i hear you well when you're paying
for it and it matters you go get it done
that's good i like that
so what was your associate what's your
associates in
business administration good good okay
and that did help you with your sales
career didn't it
oh it really did and it definitely
opened the doors um
i think it is a little bit difficult to
to get in to get interviews if you don't
have that degree and it definitely
helped me get into my last job that
where i'm currently working in 2008 i
was hired
and i don't know if i would have got the
interview if i didn't have some sort of
a degree
i don't think it mattered what it was
but it definitely helped that i went to
school yeah
good for you so a single lady 55 years
old with a million
eighty seven thousand dollar net worth
did not inherit enough to cause it to
happen
you got up you left the cave you killed
it you drug it home
no four year degree as a 32 year old
goes and gets an associate's degree you
sound like the american dream is alive
and well to me
oh you better believe it it takes a lot
of hard work my dad put a really good
work ethic in us kids and you know his
work work work and um
anybody can do it and and i didn't even
realize
i saw the call out on instagram i think
it was where you were doing
advertising for the everyday
millionaires and i thought i'm gonna you
know add up my numbers and i was shocked
that i broke the million
not by much but i was stunned when i
actually
found that i actually had hit the one
million
you know what's interesting is you did
it
you're impressive yeah you're impressive
i mean
you know i don't care if it's a million
87 i don't care if it's a million eight
i don't care if it's two million eight
you did it and a whole bunch of people
sitting around on their couches sucking
their thumbs whining acting like they're
entitled didn't do nothing
you did it well i spent i spent a lot of
time on the road and i listened to a lot
of ramsey all day long when i was
driving you know 300 miles a day and
um i finally i was davish for several
years
and finally um after i bought my last
brand new car
in 2015 i became debt free in 2016. i
was done with having debt
and um so i still have that car and
i've been working at it ever since and
and i went through some really serious
medical challenges in 27 and
2017 and 2018 and if it wasn't for my
emergency fund uh i was able to actually
focus on getting better
that matters a lot that matters a lot
i'm so proud of you
you're a hero kiddo well done very very
well done
it's an honor to speak with you it's an
everyday
millionaires theme hour we're talking to
real millionaires
this is what they sound like they're not
evil people
they're hard-working people they're
people that say
they're generous people they believe you
can do it
are you hearing them
[Music]
our scripture today psalms 84 11 for the
lord god
is a son and a shield the lord bestows
favor and honor
no good thing does he withhold from
those who
whose walk is blameless thomas payne
said reputation is what men and women
think of us
character is what god and the angels
know
of us if you've been paying attention to
this real estate market you've noticed
it's crazy out there
the competition between buyers just to
get a house is pretty intense
this is not amateur hour inventory is
too low
it's too crazy in environment you need a
pro by your side if you're selling to
get the most out
if you're buying to make sure you don't
put the most
in our agents and our endorsed local
providers program have years of industry
success they do not compromise
they're going to help you do the right
thing
and you gotta have some you gotta have
some wisdom and some calmness around you
when
things are this nuts out there instead
of somebody's adding to the drama just
to get a commission
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent get an endorsed local provider
someone we endorse locally in your area
to provide you with help
in this case in the real estate world
ramsey solutions dot com
slash agent it's a millionaire theme
hour and everyday millionaire theme hour
the book everyday millionaire is one we
publish as a number one bestseller
it is here at ramsey solutions you can
learn about the study that was done
you can learn about the conclusions of
the study and uh
powerful powerful information if you
want actually the white paper
on the book we actually sell that too so
um
and uh man this this is just an amazing
subject this idea
of becoming a millionaire
it's not a billionaire and truthfully
these days it's not a lot of money but
it's more than most people have
and it puts you in the category of not
broke anymore
and pushing the category where you are
controlling a lot more of your own
destiny you're not going to retire on
social insecurity
and get the book 738 three ways to
prepare alpo and love it
you're not going to live on dog food in
your retirement years
and these are real stories that really
happen so
you you know but but you've got to take
the steps
you've got to make the sacrifices and
we're talking to real
millionaires to find out how they did it
andy is with us and andy is in seattle
washington what is your net worth andy
hi dave um my my husband and i
our net worth is um 1.98
excellent okay break that 2 million down
for me by
sure um retirement accounts single
stocks bank stocks and gold
are 8 30 mostly retirement and mutual
funds but
and then money and checkings and savings
for various
kind of reasons kids college and stuff
is um
150 and then
our house in seattle we paid it off
oh about 10 years ago it's worth 800 now
and we have some land in pennsylvania we
have two different plots that's where my
husband's from
um they're worth a hundred each
i think that comes up to it does it that
does it does that sir
okay good how old i thought i could make
to make it go over with the car but i
i looked to kelly blue book out of cars
worth 800
i couldn't do it won't make it oh i'm
straining to the finish line
so how old are you okay i'm 50. 50 years
old good
yeah how much of this 2 million did you
guys inherit
uh my dad died about 10 years ago and
he left me 15 000. 15 000. so you're not
millionaires because of inheritance then
no okay not even close okay no
so what is your household income best
year
since you've been working in worst year
since you've been working yeah we got
married in 92 and i was looking back
our first year my husband always worked
two jobs until he got into tech
um so his first his best year
he worked let's see
as a florist and a buster at nights he
made 30
and i was a receptionist for 12. okay so
our best
our first lowest was 42 okay
yeah and then now i make 50 and he makes
100.
okay so 150. so you've never made over
200 okay
all right cool what are your what are
your careers oh
i'm a special education assistant for
seattle public schools i work with kids
with autism
and he is a ux research
got it all right cool yeah so uh what
are your degrees in
i have a bachelor's in psychology and he
has a bachelor's in psychology
a bachelor's in occupational therapy a
master's in occupational therapy
and a phd in curriculum instruction wow
we cash flowed all those degrees while
we were living in a studio
in seattle excellent yeah so what were
your gpas
um i was a 3.5 i think he was a three
free like
in under his undergrad first one i don't
know what his other ones were
no telling he's got more degrees than a
thermometer all right very good
good for you guys okay so
when you set out on this life
and he's working busboy and florist
you're making 42. did you believe you
could do this
no i i and i didn't think it would no
but you know who did he did and his
parents did because
they were on a dairy farm they both were
born on dairy farms ran a dairy farm
and were millionaires because they were
so good with their money and they had
some rentals
and they always lived beneath their
means and they gave us a book
for our wedding from larry burkett and i
read it over and over it says before the
internet you know
yeah yeah i just read it over and over
and it can i can i was convinced that we
could live
below our means books changed my life
too
yeah yeah amazing very very and then we
got
we took um fpu in 94 when it first came
out at our church
wow you were one of the earliest yeah we
were
yeah we got over on the west coast
pretty quick to seattle and spokane and
stuff
and that was some of the first financial
peace classes that were not in nashville
wow oh wow really yeah that that's
pretty cool good for you guys and so
you've been
your baby steps millionaires and you've
been following the baby steps all these
years
well yeah we kind of i kind of got
actually more back into you when covert
hit because i was working at home and i
was listening to
every day and i was like my husband
actually my husband was going through
our finances and he goes
i think we're on step seven it's like
oh my goodness really so that made me
want to look into it and
maybe call in for one of these i love it
well thank you for sharing i'm so proud
of you very very well done
very well done okay we didn't have
anybody call in
with a 10 million net worth all of these
were between
one and two million dollars of net worth
every one of them
uh high school teacher engineer mom
engineer marketing banker
uh sales person ux special ed teacher
these were the career fields
none of these people went to
mit harvard or princeton or vanderbilt
none of them well at least well i don't
know that because i didn't ask where
they went to school so
that's not true but i can tell by the
fact that they didn't have
large student loan debts by and large so
there you go
uh man oh man oh man so
52 years old 38 38 55 and 50.
i don't want to wait i'm 80. well then
don't
i want to live my life yolo well that's
being a child
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
yeah you're a child
that's children do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it if
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
so i i don't care if you want to do this
or not
but don't tell lies about what wealth
looks like in america
if you don't want to do it it's okay but
don't tell lies about it
and don't tolerate the lies i was
meeting with uh
enjoying a great conversation with a
young friend of mine who's very very
bright and he's
a real left-winger and he was talking to
me about wealth equality and i said well
equality is not fair
he said what you mean it's not fair i
said effort's not fair
effort's not equal and if people that
give out more effort don't make more
than people who sit on their butts
that's not fair
[Music]
oh there's something to think about got
his little wheels are turning
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you